ihren eigenen kandidaten das müssen sie
die fraktion in düring fragen nicht mich
ich habe da keine aktien drin das ist
mir sehr gefragt da sind so wie bei mir
falsch wenn es keine möglichkeit gibt
dass er gewählt wird oder ein anderer
bürgerlicher kandidat gewählt wird halte
ich das für richtig
und insofern halte ich es auch für klug
was die thüringer fraktion gemacht hat
aber was sie genau dazu bewogen hat da
müssen sie wirklich die thüringer
freunde fragen und das habe ich ihnen ja
gerade gesagt weil der eigene kandidat
keine chance hatte aber der fdp-kandidat
wie sich herausgestellt hat ja
offensichtlich chancen hatte und
unterstützt man die ihn in der
bürgerlichen mehrheit die eine chance
hat ich kann mir vorstellen aber dann
müssen sie die cdu und die fdp fragen
dass er die meisten chancen als
bürgerlicher kandidat gegen bodo ramelow
hatte es ist ein erster schritt das
ausgrenzung nicht funktioniert wie
weiters trägt das kann man jetzt noch
nicht sagen das kommt auch auf die
thüringer und cdu und fdp an das kann
ich nicht voraussagen
das sind zwei völlig verschiedene paar
schuhe
wir erhalten die politik von cdu und fdp
in vielen dingen für falsch das ist
völlig richtig deshalb bezeichnen wir
das auch als altparteien aber natürlich
steht uns cdu und fdp wenn es sozusagen
um einen ministerpräsidenten der linken
geht immer noch näher und sie müssen
wenn sie in der demokratie etwas
erreichen wollen sich natürlich
mehrheiten suchen die hfg nicht alleine
und von daher ist das was sie gemacht
hat völlig richtig
ich glaube das ist keine frage die man
diskutieren muss denn die aller parteien
erklärt dass sie das nicht wollen dann
also die frage nicht diskutieren
[Musik]
es wird nicht anders sein
herr ramelow hätte ja auch nur eine
minderheitsregierung gehabt das wird
jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder eine
minderheitsregierung mit cdu und fdp
weiß nicht wer vielleicht sich nach
beteiligt und die müssen sich genauso
mehrheiten für den haushalt suchen wie
sich das herr ramelow besuchen müssen
also das ist jetzt keine große änderung
da wir jetzt keine wahl haben ist das
jetzt kein thema das müssen sie die
anderen fragen es geht das signal davon
aus dass man nie eine demokratische
partei aus dem demokratischen diskurs
ausgrenzen soll das ist glaube ich schon
ein signal
aber was die basis der cdu denkt oder
was fdp-abgeordnete das müssen sie die
kollegen im bundestag und in den
landtagen fragen